[Music]
it just feels really good wow has anyone
ever cried before they you you you have
okay go so I'm not the only wi hello
everyone and welcome to a special
win-win episode an episode where you get
to see me cry over a chicken dumpling
cuz I recently visited Uma Vetti the CEO
and founder of upside Foods now upside
are one of a growing number of companies
developing what is known as cultivated
meat meat that is 100% animal but
instead of being grown on the skeleton
of an animal in a farm that meat is
grown in a bioreactor which I appreciate
sounds rather sci-fi but as someone who
is a huge meat lover and also a huge
animal lover this technology is a real
win-win in my book because I mean let's
face it the modern meat industry it
sucks especially factory farms not only
in how they treat their animals but also
what they're doing to our environment
and even to our own health with things
like antibiotic resistance so for me at
least this technology provides An
Elegant solution to the cognitive
dissonance that I often have around my
own carnivorous this episode is a look
behind the scenes of what it's taken to
bring this technology to a point where
it is almost ready for market and quick
disclaimer I am an investor in upside
Foods I wasn't paid or even asked to
make this video I just really really
believe in this technology so I'm
happily Shilling for it for reasons
you're here but please do keep that in
mind as you watch obviously that out of
the way let's dig
[Music]
in so what are we going to be trying
today uh we're going to try a number of
things that you can do with chicken he's
doing dumplings he's going to make a
breakfast sausage complete whole cut
chicken breast that we do our own
version of and then we're going to go
into Fried Chicken we wanted to pick
something very familiar chicken is the
most familiar meat people love eating
chicken in many forms and we're like
let's not compromise that experience
people should recognize that when it
hits their taste Birds oh yeah I know
that yes so as you can imagine I was
pretty excited to try this stuff but
first let's hear how Uma went from being
a cardiologist to a cultivated meat
grower when I was 12 I went to a
friend's birthday party our neighbor we
were in the front of the house having a
lot of fun and then I just walked to the
back of the house and in the back of the
house were was where they were
slaughtering the animals to feed the
people in the front I think that was the
first time ever I came face to face with
The
Duality um of meat production I didn't
do anything about it then I kept eating
meat I loved eating meat and then I went
to medical school so we had this group
of 50 60 kids that were in one medical
school I volunteered to run the
cafeteria and during that time I used to
go with the chefs and the Su chefs to
the market and buy all of the produce
and all of the stuff one day we went to
actually the meat the slaughter house
and I saw for the first time intensified
intense animal production
operations and that was like a moment I
can't forget I'm like on a chain there
was 60 chickens every second being
slaughtered moved to the next thing
slaughtered moved to the next
thing I did not know how to react but I
think those two moments the birthday
death day when I was 12 years old and
this was when I was 18 years
old I'm like okay I I love eating meat
but I'm going to stop eating meat and I
that's what that's the choice I made for
myself I didn't tell anyone and then I
came to the US to do Cardiology at the
mayor Clinic I was fortunate to be able
to you know get there and as I was was
training to be a cardiologist
Interventional cardiologist we also
started working on stem cells and stem
cells are these incredibly versatile
cells in every person's body are also
animals bodies where these cells can do
anything they can become muscle they can
become connective tissue they can become
bone they can become brain cells and
what we were doing were taking those
cells and injecting them into patients
Hearts when they had a heart attack or a
cardiac arested as I started thinking
about it I'm like could we actually do
this with animals and take sales from an
animal and grow meat and that was
somewhere in the range of I think 2005
or so that idea came into my head and I
I could not get it out I just could not
get it I tried really hard because there
was lots of things going on in
cardiology but every morning I wake up
and that thought comes back to my mind
so I started talking about that with my
friends my family and finally people
they got fed up with me talking about it
and I doing anything and they said why
are you not doing
it so that became a call to
action but how does it work like how can
you begin to grow meat without its host
animal so the process starts from with
us taking cells from either a adult
animal young animal or a egg it's a
small biopsy and a biopsy usually gets
you one or two drops worth of cells from
any part of the animal and once we do
that we take take those cells and we
grow them outside the animal with
nutrients and identify the animal cells
that do a fantastic job of growing and
retaining the flavor and the textures
they are the ones that graduate to
become a commercial breed at upside once
they do that we don't have to go back to
the animal so for instance these
chickens uh products you're eating today
we got them from uh the source about
four or 5 years ago from a chicken um
and we haven't had to go back we can
keep producing with that for the next
next 30 Years the DNA is identical to
the sort of old school style of chicken
yeah I mean the DNA here is chicken DNA
like right if you just go and do put it
through any DNA reading um and ask it to
read what species is this it'll say gas
gas so the DNA question is probably the
biggest misunderstanding I keep hearing
about cultivated meat people
understandably assume that it must be
genetically modified in some way in
order to grow but it's not it's
genetically identical to whatever farmed
animal the cell samples originally come
from so it's not a GMO food what is
different though is how much time and
energy and space it takes to grow the
meat especially when you compare it
pound forp pound to current methods any
meat takes about two weeks maybe it
takes three weeks maybe it takes four
weeks if you're trying to add some
Exquisite features into it right but
let's say it averages out at 2 weeks or
let's push it to 3 weeks when you
compare that with a cow which is 2 years
a pig which is 9 months and a chicken
which is 2 months and then lamb is about
6 months like it's just a much shorter
process 4X to almost you know 50x and in
terms of Energy Efficiency um again like
I don't know if you can make a
comparison but how much energy it would
take you know takes to get a a kilogram
of steak versus a kilogram of steak
grown you know grown in a lab what how
much more energy is that so we have our
own work that we've done and started to
say at scale when we project out our
production methods the efficiency and
the time it takes for us to grow the
meat and compare with the literature out
there the majority of it is saying
unequivocally that when we get to scale
of you know tens of millions of pounds
or hundreds of millions of pounds the
land use goes down to about
90% less than what we need for
conventional meat
the water use goes down by about 90
plus% to what it requires to feed an
animal before it slaughtered and the
greenhouse gas emissions also go down by
about 90% so those three things
greenhouse gas emissions land use water
water use go down about 90% we have 70
billion animals right now drinking a
third of all the fresh water that we
have in the world using a third of all
the aable land to make the feed for them
and if the demand for meat is doubling
simple math that means animals will be
drinking 2/3 of all the fresh water 30
years from now that's on Earth and 2/3
of all the agricultural land is going to
be used to grow crops for feeding
animals to feed humans that math won't
work out and the thing is he is right as
more and more poor countries modernize
Trends show that their demand for meat
will significantly increase which is
going to make our current very
inefficient farming system even more
unsustainable long-term a statistic that
really blows my mind is just how much
the distribution of biology on Earth has
changed since the Agricultural
Revolution before humans started farming
we only made up a tiny sliver of all the
biomass on earth now we in our livestock
represent 98% of all biomass that's more
than a 10,000x increase much of which
has only happened in the last couple
hundred years so such a rapid swing is
obviously going to create a huge shock
on any ecosystem But ultimately I can
stats around all day long and none of
this matters if this meat doesn't
actually taste good or at least taste as
good as what you can buy in a
supermarket so here is my rather
emotional taste test does the product
feel different in any way to cook with
no we uh we've kind of put it through
its Paces you know we've kind of tried
all sorts of stuff we've fried it we've
brinded it we've smoked it we've made
sausages we've made kind of everything
that you could kind of imagine and yeah
it really acts in the same way as you
would expect chicken this is the pot
stickers so like Uma said this is a
cultivated chicken it has some ginger
scallion kind of traditional seasonings
in there have you ever taste of
cultivated meat by the way I have never
tasted cultivated meat before I have
been waiting years to do this as someone
who like I love meat but I love animals
and I love Earth this is like this is
the ultimate win-win
technology I'm quite actually emotional
about it like I can't believe I'm about
to finally taste this wow we're so glad
you're doing that you're upside thank
you tastes like
chicken
wow it is chicken it tastes exactly the
same it's so
good
it's I mean it's it's I don't think I
but there's no way I could tell the
difference that's amazing thank you for
saying that this is the reaction we get
every single time people come in and
taste it it just feels really good
wow we have a lot more prod so impressed
I'm so impressed has anyone ever cried
before when they you have you you have
okay go so I'm not the only
one it's
actually I can't believe it's real can't
believe it's real so yes I can
definitively say it passed the taste
test at least to me but of course the
question you're probably all wondering
is what are the health and safety
implications of this technology I mean
after all we've evolved to eat meat
conventionally for thousands of years
and this is as far away from nature as
you can get really so how can these
companies ensure that it lives up to
safety and nutritional standards
presumably you you don't actually have
any you can't have any long-term studies
right on the effect of humans eating
cultivated meat because it's so new you
know the first person ate what in 2013
Mark Post bger in March in 2013 AUST
about 10 years ago is the first time
that was eaten publicly televised but
there have been people who have been
tasting it before that and at various
small events but you're right it all has
been happening in the last 10 15 years
are there any studies planned to sort of
measure the the you know the effects on
people who have been eating it
consistently and so on because I imagine
there's going to be a lot of people who
you know aren't willing to try it until
there is some sort of long-term study I
think there will be you know I get calls
from people that are very interested in
doing studies and uh people that have
scientifically rigorous things that want
to do long-term studies and I said those
should happen they will happen as they
should happen in a very well-designed
fashion it'll take time to make all of
these studies happen but it'll come back
to the challenge which is what do you
compare it with where is the gold
standard what do you
accept if you accept a third of us could
develop cancers from the food that we
eat that's we're already at that level
right now right so in scientific design
of a proper study that can be
interpreted well we really have to keep
those things in mind and start
questioning that because that's also
changed over time there's so many of
these caveats that we need to think
about designing studies and what I would
say is let's step back let's step back
and say are there any studies that just
say I'm going to put people in in eating
conventional meat only category and
people that don't eat any meat at all in
their diet category do we actually have
really strong evidence to say one group
is at a higher risk than the other group
now that study has not been done then in
that case if you do a meta study on top
of it without a proper Foundation it
becomes very challenging to interpret so
the the way we approach it is the
following we're like let's make sure
that we know everything possible about
the cell we know everything possible
about the nutrition that is going into
these cells and we know the growing
conditions and everything that we do is
trackable how can you ensure that the
meat products are as healthy for you as
you know say a chicken breast I would go
buy you know from a conventional
conventional Farm or you know perhaps
more more more accurately let's let's
compare it to like a factory farm that's
not you know we can compare to free
range as well but maybe factory farms
which is where you know 90% of meat is
coming from nowadays right so we think
about putting products that are
nutritionally rich and part of a
well-balanced diet conven meat as we
know it and processed Meats as we know
it have been associated with certain
diseases whether it's cardiovascular
disease or cancers or chronic diseases
or diseases that could lead to
inflammation now when I step back as a
physician and think about what are we
trying to really do here I think the
opportunity with cultivated meat to
start making meat better is
significantly higher than you can ever
imagine with conventional meat and a
couple of examples
if if we know how to select cells that
are capable of giving us the right
omega-3 Omega 6 ratios suddenly it's
like okay can I make beef with the
health benefits for the heart like a
salmon right right those possibilities
open up and that's when you know my
lights my eyes light up our team's eyes
light up and say yes we see that we can
start thinking about touching that
future do you need to use uh because I
know in conventional farming and
especially in factory farming
the amount of antibiotic usage is uh I I
couldn't find the exact numbers on what
percentage of antibiotics worldwide
actually given to farm animals but it's
a very significant amount um which is
obviously contributing to antibiotic
resistance um and you know other sort of
growing threats um and you know people
are quite understandably concerned about
the idea that they're ingesting you know
meat from animals that have been
consuming so many antibiotics do you
have to use them in your systems answer
is no all the products you ate they
never saw antibiotics wow and that's
what's going to be another distinct
advantage of cultivated meat right as we
start scaling our production techniques
and keep going to scale people are going
to see that and 60 to 80% of all the
antibiotics made in the United States
are made for animals not for humans
that's a very large percentage so what's
happening to all of that antibiotics the
animal is eating and then it's secreting
it or excreting it and it gets into the
runoff and then we get exposed to that
and there's a lot of worry about
antibiotic resistance and we've seen
lots of antibiotic resistance organisms
with hundreds of thousands of people
being affected every year and tens of
thousands dying from it so that's one
distinct Advantage the second one is
pandemic risk I worry about that even
more because antibiotic resistance major
problem can affect pockets of people and
it could be a slow rolling
disaster when you suddenly think about
pandemics the biggest risk that we are
facing and looking at every day in the
eye is if you're are confining 70
billion animals every year in tiny tiny
areas and those animals are so close to
each other in the middle of breathing
infectious agent circulating and
excreting the excrement all being in one
place it's like a pet Tre dish it's the
literal petri dish talk about an entire
lab grown experiment in the world that
we do every single second right on a
massive massive scale that is the lab
grown experiment that I'm very scared of
we've lived that through the pandemic of
what it can cause to our lives and due
to our lives I lost my dad with from
covid and he's a veterinarian he and we
used to talk about this pandemic risk
always zadic diseases spreading from an
animal either wild animal or a
domesticated animal jumping into humans
always talked about it it just is really
sad that I lost my dad to
it but when these things start happening
to people we've got to be able to say
let's open our eyes wide let's look at
opportunities where we can decrease that
risk I'd love to get into the sort of
more uh economic side of all of this Do
It um so initially um the production
of I think a pound of beef through
cultivated meat was $188,000 a pound
chicken was $9,000 a pound um where was
where is the price down to approximately
now and where do you you know how do you
plan to scale it so that it becomes like
commercially competitive to Conventional
meat this is a fantastic question comes
every single day for us and our answer
is there's three things we're focusing
on people have to fall in love with the
product people have to be able to affort
it and then people have to be able to
see how it's made those are a must have
how do we take care of the first taste
thing that's the first magical thing for
people to see they have to come into
into a kitchen see it being cooked and
taste right we're never going to pass
the sniff test if you don't get across
that so that was the laser focus for the
last for the first 3 four years the
focus is cost we're like we want to be
able to put this product on the market
it's going to be expensive to make it in
the early days but we do want to be able
to price it for a consumer in the range
of a premium meat product that they're
going to be able to go and buy at a
restaurant if they're buying a chicken
sandwich if they're paying $15 for a
chicken sandwich now they're like we
want to be able to capture a slight
premium on that because it helps us
continue to do the research and
Innovation right so what we are thinking
is price it above organic in the range
of 30% or so above organic that we think
a lot of people can start affording to
pay right now enough for us to be able
to keep building the business and start
saying we'll get to closer and closer to
Conventional meat price parity which
will be another 50% lower than what an
organic uh chicken costs right now those
are what our not stars are and our first
products that we'll put on the market
will be in that
range the cost of manufacturing it is
higher right now because we're doing it
in small scale a lot more biscope bisoke
craft type of manufacturing but when we
are building the next commercial
facility based on what we are sitting in
right now that is focused on bringing
the cost of chicken to $10 a pound wow
that's the goal we've got the next one
is to get it to $5 a pound I think that
is kind of where it's going if we use
today's prices what about the role of
subsidies because I think what a lot of
people don't realize is you know a lot
of the meat and food that we eat is
already very Subs subsidized right um is
that the case with meat and do you think
it could be the case with cultivated
meat too the conventional industry has
taken advantage of enormous amounts of
subsidies incentives loan programs tax
benefits to get to a place of efficiency
that they're at right now right that
took several decades for them to get
there and there has been incredible
amount of taxpayer
support and public private
Partnerships and I think if we have to
be realistic and say a transformative
change like this should
be should be funded similar to that
that's a Level Playing Field and we will
have to be eligible for all of these
same benefits that conventional meat
industry has been able to Avail for
cultivated meat to go to the next level
and there's great examples of that that
we've been living through think about
the energy transformation happening
right now the infrastructure act the
chips act the IRA all of these are
offering an ability for American
manufacturing to be able to compete with
Chinese manufacturing or some other
manufacturing location so on that note
let's finish up with the main course of
the day a full cultivated chicken breast
filet unlike ground chicken a full filet
like you'd get straight off the breast
of a living chicken is of course much
harder to produce given all the senu and
nerves and stuff that nor hold a breast
muscle together but they've even cracked
that too so this is the high water mark
for our company this is the same product
that's going to Domin CR so it looks
exactly how how this looks is what's we
sending to her and it's all made here in
the facility so this is um over 99% way
to
meat yeah so this is made with a
different process than the previous the
products so in this method of production
for the chicken breast what we have is
we have the cells together and we keep
them close enough that they actually
start attaching to each other physically
and they start forming the Junctions and
attach and then they line up in a file
and that's what you need for a fiber and
then they are stacked up against each
other and then they start becoming more
and more fibers and then the cells
themselves secrete something called The
extracellular Matrix basically collagens
and elastins that hold them together so
therefore when you pull out the chunk of
meat it's all staying
together excuse my Ferness but I want to
I want to experience the actual
texture so you see how
close just straight up to your
[Music]
breast just
what this is the world we should live in
where we can have all the protein that
we need and
want um without the like endless
suffering and environmental degradation
that comes with
there we go thank you so much for
watching everyone and of course huge
thank you to Uma and his team upside for
letting me come ask them questions for
letting me Grill them there you go
there's the pun of pun of the day anyway
if you found this interesting or useful
please share um I'm also really curious
to know if you would actually try this
meat if it was given to you you know
offered offered on a plate let me know
what you think in the comments but
either way I'm really hopeful that this
meat will become an option for those who
would like to try it soon uh cuz as I
said I think it's a massive win-win it's
a win-win win-win animals environment
People's Health uh
sustainability doesn't mean you can't
eat conventional meat anymore that will
still be there um it's all about choice
maximization so anyway on that note
thank you and I'll see you next
[Music]
time